Thank you very much. Thanks to you, I feel much better now. Please
get some more rest. I'm
in the staff room. Yes, Yama-san, I'm
sorry. Sometimes my ahi legs
hurt, so I take painkillers, but this morning I was so
nervous about going to school for the first time that I forgot.  If
I had helped her properly after that accident, she wouldn't have felt
this way.Nee,
Momijiyama-san, Momijiyama-san, you kind of
look like one of our employees.The hero's deception.I suddenly
thought about it when I was called out to on the stairs earlier.  For
some reason, I've always had to be saved, even though I've been saved from my injuries.The
sight of a hero coming to help you when you're on the brink of death must be a common sight, but it's hard to forget when it's about me.
When I thought about becoming something, you just
looked like a hero.I'm
sorry, but that's strange.Does
Koishika-san hold a grudge against Shii?
Why would she do that?
If Shai had helped her properly, she would have gotten hurt.
Everyone thinks that she lived without it, but that's not the case.
There's no one who hates someone who does their best for someone else. She
definitely saved me, just like Ms.
Momiyama.  I'm
sorry for losing you. Don't
worry, I hope you're
okay. I'm sorry. Things will change.